in the not so distant future the world
is going to be a very different place
china is becoming the world's biggest
economy we would expect china to
overtake the united states pretty
quickly perhaps around the turn of the
decade in 2013. its share of global
trade actually increased at a record
clip
china's meteoric economic rise is
unprecedented in history there's
something called china time where
everything happens so much faster
the reality of the last 40 years has
been a radical shift from agrarian
poverty at the end of the mao era to
something which looks like a comfortable
middle class life
opening up to market capitalism in the
late 70s kickstarted a new era
the trappings of western capitalism are
now ubiquitous in china
but so too is the iron fist of the state
while it undoubtedly comes at a cost
this central control has allowed beijing
to nurture long-term economic strategies
china has transformed itself into a
green energy powerhouse that produces
most of the world's solar panels wind
turbines and lithium-ion batteries
by 2030 china is poised to grab the
lion's share of jobs and wealth as the
world gradually transitions away from
fossil fuels
and it's become fertile ground for
electric car makers
gm we believe
china will be one of the main epicenters
in the globe of the adoption or the
transformation towards the
electrification
china is rewriting the rules of global
capitalism can the rest of the world
keep up
you know the president is concerned that
china is far ahead of us it is time for
that to shift around
[Music]
while china has become a leader in
multiple green industries the progress
it has made in electric vehicles or evs
is unparalleled
the evolution of the automobile in the
20th century caused an economic
revolution in the united states
after losing out to international car
makers for decades china has learnt to
leapfrog the combustion engine
the country is already home to the
planet's largest market for evs by sales
and it still has room to grow
electric cars account for five percent
of sales today but beijing is aiming for
that figure to hit 40
by 2030.
back in 2001 beijing drew up the 863
initiative to strengthen the
competitiveness of china in the global
economy
it invested a relatively small amount
about 130 million dollars into three new
energy vehicle technologies
fuel cell hybrid and electric
these guided china's green vehicle
development for the next 15 years
there's a technology race on renewable
energy and electric cars that's emerging
between the united states and china
right now china is ahead on electric
cars because the government has had a
very strong policy supporting electric
cars now for a number of years i've been
going to china for about 25 years and
the changes are just amazing when i
first went to china the streets were
filled with swarms swarms and swarms of
bicyclists almost in this graceful
swimming thing as people were bicycling
to work all gone just streets now jammed
and you can sit there in the longest
traffic jams
i've ever been in and that's just one
side of a sign of the change
they realize that there's one global
market where they cannot be competitive
they're too late the traditional
gasoline petrol powered car but they see
themselves if they can get at the
forefront on electric vehicles and
almost half the world's electric cars
now are in china that will give them a
foundation to be very strong competitors
in the global automobile market of the
future which they are not now
this technological leapfrogging means
many of us haven't seen or even heard of
some of china's biggest automakers
we delivered 2.1 million cars to the
market globally and
we
achieved
50 billion us dollars revenue
like so many other chinese companies
gili had grown into a behemoth long
before it started to operate abroad now
it owns volvo has a stake in daimler and
is listed internationally
gili isn't selling as many cars as tesla
just yet but it is able to launch bold
new concepts in an environment that
actively encourages innovation such as
its new rapid battery swap stations we
have the plan to build over 2000
charging stations and batteries web
solutions in the next couple years
to allow more than 20 000
charging points
this is a technology tesla didn't think
western countries were ready for it's
amazing if you go back two decades china
was a tiny automobile market one or two
million cars a year now it's like 27
million cars a year which is like 50
percent bigger than the u.s market so
that gives them a test bed
for promoting electric cars which
they're doing aggressively it also means
that the automobile makers of the world
and remember the automobile business is
a global business they may be focused on
the united states but they also want to
sell electric cars and be competitive in
china
[Applause]
china's vast domestic market 400 million
middle class car buyers means that major
international car makers have to invest
and compete there
beijing may be able to take advantage of
that to further its strategic ambition
of clean tech dominance but that's not
to say it's a hard sell for foreign car
companies
the city of legion
thanks to a green push by local
authorities it's effectively become the
capital of the biggest eevee market in
the world they basically have created uh
lanes in the city where the electric
cars can go
like normal combustion engines can't
and the majority of these electric cars
are three meters long cost less than
five thousand dollars
and outsell teslas they've created uh
dedicated parking spaces that are half
the size of normal parking spaces that
can only be used by this so you've
created an environment where it's it's
an advantage in that city to have a hong
kong mini ev so it's a it's a positive
example
of how to encourage usage
of products that drives helps drive
consumer behavior
the cars are made by a chinese company
called wuling in partnership with a very
famous american company general
motorsports
[Music]
once a symbol of american industrial
might general motors has to now look
outside the u.s for opportunity
china has become the company's biggest
market and is by far the most
strategically important the chinese
consumer is very tech savvy this means
you've got a very fertile ground to try
new things to experiment and to get
people to adopt new technology
every car we make we sell and this is
not regulation driven this is pure
customer demand that is driving the need
for us to supply that product to
consumers
in china electric car buyers can get
subsidies worth thousands of dollars
in some cities getting a parking permit
for a conventional combustion engine car
has become nearly impossible
at the end of 2020 the country had 1.68
million charging points for evs
compare that with 72 000 in the us at
the end of 2019 the vast majority of
chinese driving habits and actual miles
driven or kilometers driven is in an
urban environment which obviously suits
the the adoption of electric vehicles if
you look at the hong kong mini ev
we have ranges of 170 kilometers 120
kilometers but for the vast majority of
our consumers that it's either a second
car or it's a primary car in a real
downtown area that's adequate because of
driving conditions and the charging of
the structure mean that you've got a
very high adoption rate and not so many
barriers to adoption
there's a clear tipping point around the
250 300
mile mark in the us that is because a
lot of consumers in the us drive you
know city to city
so that's a big part of
life that's a little different in china
85 percent of miles driven are driven in
a non-highway environment
the chinese aren't just transforming the
ev market
a government-led top-down approach also
rewrites the rules of innovation
in the western conception
the entrepreneur is critical in the
innovation process
it's the entrepreneur the bill gates the
jeff bezos and the financial incentive
that innovation will deliver enormous
wealth that's the catalyst for the
innovation process
that's part of the picture but as we're
discovering in china it's not the entire
picture
a government which is willing to
patiently
pour resources
time
money
people
into solving problems and pushing
innovation forward can also deliver some
impressive results
the majority of the cars gm sells in
china are made in china which means the
company has to walk on eggshells to stay
in beijing's good graces
it represents the dilemma most foreign
companies face in the country
to catch up in clean tech
there's a trade-off my name is joe biden
and i'm a car guy which is why
investment in ev charging stations as
part of president biden's new 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure plan you
know the president is concerned that
china is far ahead of us in the electric
vehicle market and instead of producing
the technologies of the future we're
importing them from somewhere else it is
time for that to shift around not
everyone on biden's team is alarmed
though
i would venture to guess that the vast
majority
of all patents and innovations in the
cleantech space has been funded by the
department of energy and by private
sector players within the united states
they were commercialized largely i would
say in europe through the feed and
tariff programs and
in china through their manufacturing
prowess
but a lot of the technology really
originated here in the united states
but i think if you were to think about
what the most innovative electric
vehicles are in the world you'd think of
tesla and i think when you think about
who all of the players including the
chinese players want to emulate it's
american innovation it's not chinese
innovation
the current lithium-ion value technology
really no one believes that that current
technology will be relevant in 2030.
whether it's the cathode or the anode or
the electrolyte or the substrates i
think everyone sees a dramatic amount of
innovation in the next generation
battery storage which is what we're
scaling up here in the united states
there are facets to china's success in
clean tech that are problematic to say
the least
its booming solar industry has been
accused of relying to some degree on
forced labor
where systemic oppression of muslim
uighurs is an international human rights
issue
china is also the world's biggest
greenhouse gas emitter and is home to
huge environmental problems mainly
thanks to its reluctance to rain in its
massive coal industry
when severe air pollution swept across
the country in the winter of 2013
beijing tilted further towards green car
policies
over the past 30 days the average air
quality level in this city has
registered as hazardous on the official
scale
by 2019 the government had designed a
world-beating system of regulatory
targets which has required automakers to
accelerate investment and sales of
electric cars faster than they might
have left to their own devices
all this has set china on course for
2030 where the country will have an
outsized influence in this strategic
industry with a big say over technical
standards and terms of trade the big
question
the chinese state-sponsored conception
of capitalism worked really well when
china was catching up
borrowing from or some would say
stealing technologies from the rest of
the world
will it work so well when china has
reached the technology frontier and
needs to innovate through it
i think you could have two scenarios
one is it actually doesn't look too
different a lot more electric cars on
the road traffic's still a really big
problem
the other is uh what i describe in the
new map is auto tech where you take
electric cars put it together with ride
hailing put it together with
self-driving autonomous vehicles and you
have these very large fleets of cars
self-driving that just come and pick
people up and people don't really
identify with their car anymore it's
just a utility a facility and it's kind
of moving in a very different way and
you don't have traffic jams because
everybody is well coordinated so it's
all these vehicles are tied together by
software so i think it's not a
prediction of one or the other but
rather two scenarios a lot depends upon
the pace of technology and i think a lot
depends upon how this competition and
interdependence at the same time between
china and the united states plays out
cutting edge evs rely on a lot of
software and data for onboard navigation
charging wireless updates and remote
diagnostics
that's a sensitive area given efforts in
the us and europe to restrain tech
transfers to china and could damage
development if not handled carefully
[Music]
as china continues to grow and lead this
industry it will almost certainly have a
bigger say in the outcome for everyone
else
[Music]
[Music]
you